we are going to begin this hour with the
bang I'm very excited about this story
we are exploring one of the oldest
crafts in culinary history as part of
our series the dish bread in one shape
or another is part of every culture on
the planet and baking evidence of it
anyway has been traced back as far as 14
000 years it's older than the Old
Testament now in the basement of a
former Oreo cookie factory here in New
York City a baker named Amadou Lee is
continuing to the tradition passed on as
it often is by a highly respected Mentor
while adding a few twists of his own
at elf Bakery inside New York's Chelsea
Market you can hear the bread before you
taste it that's a good crack right there
and of course when you do taste it
um
from the brioche and the babka to the
croissants and the country loaves what
are you having not to mention those big
beautiful sourdoughs on the back Shelf
just about everything it out qualifies
as one of Humanity's all-time favorite
combinations of flour water and yeast
what is it about bread
I mean I think it's life
great is life
founder and head Baker Amadou Lee knew
exactly what he wanted from Alf people
to walk in Chelsea Market and they'll
find this hidden small bakery that is
artisanal
because I like the artisanal Thing feel
meaning there's only so much every day
and when it's gone it's gone yes that's
the idea if we see a lot we sell out
tradition lies behind everything at elf
go go go you spend too much time on this
which Lee runs with a general's
Authority and an artist attention to
detail
good bread he believes demands that kind
of rigor it sounds like it takes a lot
of patience it does are you a patient
man I'm a dude I'm trying to be
but for someone who Embraces tradition
Lee also bakes something unconventional
you want to try to get these edges
together
why is it so important because the
layers that's where you're gonna create
a perfect layers it begins as a silky
blend of butter and dough folded as if
starting a classic croissant it's
stretched see the butter has slowly
disappear into the dough because it has
a nice temperature and set aside perfect
allowing the mixture to rest I'd like
the dog gonna tear or the butter gonna
break but then Lee shapes that dough
around the dough of a traditional
baguette
merging two French Classics into one
this is the laminated baguette how do
you know this is working
I'm looking for this Simplicity that is
not really quite simple Salt Fat dough
all together that's what I'm looking for
I'm not looking for anything else it's
an unexpected bread from an unexpected
Baker were you always a curious kid yes
that's why I end up here
born in Senegal Lee got bored after 15
years as a pastry chef at some of New
York's best restaurants something fancy
I'm I don't believe in that anymore you
know I'm very creative you know I've
done crazy desserts and all of that but
at the end of the day it's just like I
want an apple pie you know that's it
makes me it makes me happy a visit in
2014 to Arcade Bakery known for the best
baguettes and croissants in New York
would change Lee's life I took a
croissant in a coffee
I sat down I ate in the croissant
literally less than a minute
was delicious it was unbelievable just
gone in a minute yes Lee asked founder
and head Baker of arcade Roger Corral
for an internship and growl agreed so
ahmedi walks in what were your first
impressions well Amadou makes a pretty
strong first impression and you are
attracted to people who are passionate
in the same things that you are so that
was very obvious so I have code you know
what I'm going to spend three months
with this guy
and then three months which these guys
become four and a half years
but what Lee didn't know was that goral
had been struggling with rheumatoid
arthritis a condition that would force
him to give up baking the way he loved
and shut down arcade in 2019. I had a
certain way of working which was very
Hands-On which was very active and I
just didn't want to transform the bakery
into something else where I couldn't be
a role model like I wanted to be he goes
I want to sell the bakery if you want to
be part of the new bakery it's up to you
if you want to leave with the knowledge
that you learn from me and do it
somewhere else
is up to you as well
and that's when Lee set off on his own
goral is rooting for him to succeed of
course not because he feels like it's
his legacy too but because they're both
part of the much larger Legacy of bread
making
so many of the products that we do are
owned by the universe what do you mean
owned by the universe
you're getting knowledge receiving
Knowledge from your mentors and that's
part of this chain that connects you for
thousands of years through all these
different people who contributed to this
craft fold stage I come in here I can do
this all day for me it's meditative you
know it's like the fascination on Bakers
this is late night hours but they find
peace it's important have you found
peace I did
it's beautiful
I see why you were so excited about this
story you've been talking about it for
quite some time yeah because I I love
the tradition of bread making how it
goes back thousands of years literally
there's nothing else in our lives that
touches the ancestors in that kind of
way and here we have it and we
participate in that very same tradition
you know like the people who came before
us were cooking over fire in ancient
ovens and here we have Amadou cooking
this for us this morning and we get to
eat it it's an amazing thing Amadou says
bread is life I like it what he said
Simplicity that is not quite so simple
yes exactly that bread rolled in another
piece oh yeah so this is called a
laminated baguette uh and it is a
croissant dough wrapped around baguette
dough uh his mentor Roger gorrell uh
pioneered it like Roger um this is I
think it's the only Bakery in New York
that makes this uh it's gonna go fast
the crew has been eyeing it already it's
very good it's it's just delicious
fantastic Tony and you know I also love
that Amadou was in some of the fanciest
restaurants in New York City making
pastries for more than a decade and it
got to a point where he said you know
this is not who I want to be serving
with my food just that privileged
exclusive Society of fine dining he
literally wanted to be making your daily
bread and and that's the goal without is
to be making deliciousness on a daily
basis that people go home with you like
it it's so good you know what you know
what the thing about it it's good
without butter it has Butter there you
go oh but I always put butter on stuff
it's good without butter no I know and
it's not even warmed up you can warm
this up just a little bit and turn into
something completely different
completely unadorned it is where can we
go to find Amadou where do we go Chelsea
Market uh which is on 14th Street it's
it's worth a trip uh this is gonna be
around for a very long time and it's
terrific the crew is going to love this
you guys are going to love this and we
love the crow